and she pushed me down the bed you
started kissing down my body which is
hilarious
cuz I'm 17 I'm naked I'm fat I have no
beard I look like a giant fat baby she
was kissing one one one
[Music]
[Applause]
you know from the bonfire on SiriusXM
please give it up for mr. biagas I might
tell y'all's a little story about how
and who I lost my virginity to so it's
gonna be gross not on her and she was a
hot chick she was older than me I was
actually 17 minute lost my virginity she
was 22 years old and not a girlfriend or
anything just a neighbor girl 22 year
old neighbor girl she live with her
uncle next door which was weird he was a
weird guy he dressed like Gallagher but
it was like 1995 final horizontal
stripes and big like Merchant Marine
bell-bottoms any he'll who knows what
was going on there she must have been
damaged because one day I was walking by
and she goes you know what I'm gonna
make you a man and I was like okay lady
she was older and had expectations on
the whole deal so she was a guard you
got to get a hotel room am i cool well
now we got to get my mom involved in
this project I don't have a credit card
and luckily I come from great
white-trash roots like really like
backstage into Kid Rock concert my mom
was like here you go
she gave me a credit card and I booked
the room at a Holiday Inn and I remember
going yeah I said I come from garbage
my mom loves her boys she's gonna deny
me that sweet sweet can't let your mom
block where the did you guys
grow up your mom wouldn't get you laid
come on man my mom got me laid a few
times meanness thrown up in a hotel and
we walk in the room and I was very
nervous and it was very dark and it
smelled like mothballs and Febreze and
she was pouring me like this wine no
plastic cup and I'm a kid so I'm like
this is bitter and she's like drink it
and she had a boombox yeah with the
Enigma CD playing do you remember Nick
but by any chance
it's like chance he dance music it's
terrifying in this capacity I'm already
nervous they got this one that I don't
want I can't see anything and just
blaring in the rooms like whoa
I was just like Hello she goes take off
your clothes I was just all very like
rape victim II about it I've never
looked here just I got naked I thought
we were gonna start having sex I thought
it's how it all worked but she was 22
she knew what she was doing and she just
took over and she pushed me down the bed
and she started kissing down my body
which is hilarious because I'm 17 I'm
naked I'm fat I have no beard I look
like a giant fat baby that's how I
looked she was kissing like one long one
[Applause]
and then she started sucking my dick and
I was like I like this part
this parts fantastic I thought she was
gonna keep doing that but she didn't she
started doing some promos I wasn't quite
ready for she holds up my dick start
licking my balls doing a little crowd
work if you will and here is what I
learned about my balls that night and I
can't speak for all the balls but these
balls these two ticklish very very
ticklish and I wanted her to stop but I
don't want her to stop everything so I'm
just trying not to laugh through the
ball licking part but it's hard because
she was looking my balls hilariously
hilariously she was licking them and
vibrating them with her mouth and saying
the word balls which is a weird thing to
do I was even trying to pay attention
but she was like ball
lo-lo's ah
Zod's my eyes were tearing at my face
was all purple I was biting my lips but
I didn't laugh I did great and then she
did something that nobody should ever do
unannounced to a virgin she went lower
than the balls you get over Zion lower
than the balls the balls I'm laying on
my back balls and then lower than the
moon Los Angeles meheeco in layman's
terms she touched her tongue to my
butthole
and that too much for me too much I was
a virgin and one explosion of life I
laughed out loud peed one squirt and
fart in her face
[Applause]
perhaps whoops whoops I said whoops and
whoops doesn't cover that whoops it's
like I knocked over your beer or we
bumped shoulders oh hey man whoops
whoops is not farting down your throat
that is not no that's just not in the
book of whoops
and I've gummed it whoops then I tried
to be positive I was like you know what
you probably won't even smell it
honestly that was right in the chops but
she did smell it I don't know if she
burped or what but it just was in the
room and when a woman smells your fart
and you don't want her to you panic you
start thinking too quick you have
terrible ideas I tried to yell over the
smell I remember thinking us that's all
I had to offer was volume
she's like what's that smell like what
smell who a lot of each questions for
what
open a window
if you smells and I put on a condom and
I remember faking an orgasm
I don't even finish the first time I
went oh that was a go to the bathroom
and I flushed the condom and I was like
wow there's so much I just lied but she
continued to have sex with me for
several months after that and I remember
she moved back home with her parents in
a different town in South Jersey and we
were still hooking up so I was you know
a 17 year old kid getting laid so I'm
like I'll Drive out to you and she's
like that'd be great and I drove like 45
minutes to go see her one day now
I'm Jewish I'm only mentioning that for
the next part of the story it never
seems to come up anywhere my life that I
would have to give a but I pull up
to this house and she comes running out
and she goes oh my god I almost forgot
that you're Jewish and I made it it's a
weird thing I'm so sorry I should have
warned you about this but I'm like what
do you mean and we walk into her house
her father's a Nazi sympathizer and I
mean it looks like Edward Norton's
bedroom in American History X is big
Nazi flags and like like a skull with
like a knife and that's it's crazy
there was rat experiments in the
basement and I'm not making that up but
I liked banging his daughter and my last
name is not Jewish
so I get my stupid Jew mouth shut
continue to plow this chick for a while
and then I really got faced with it one
night he loved me he didn't know which I
thought was kind of good revenge because
we were right in his house I bang her
there all the time and he ordered pizza
once and I remember sitting at the table
I had my moment
goes man a pizza cost $18 now that's cuz
the Jew bastards on all the
banks pieces of and I was just
holding pizza I was like I heard that
dude and I started it please
he got understands the small victories
five minutes later I was up banging his
daughter to Forrest Gump
soundtrack or something you're welcome
for the boners everybody thank you so
much